[Musique]
donald trump de retour de sa partie de
golf n'a pas l'air de vouloir lâcher
quoi que ce soit il continue à refuser
catégoriquement la défaite notamment sur
twitter
certes depuis quelques heures il n'écrit
plus qu'il a gagnés sur les réseaux
sociaux ces derniers jours
la bibliothèque présidentielle de donald
trump un compte twitter est aussi un
site internet vous allez voir le tweet
le plus partagé est sûrement celui de
cette américaine qui se demande qui
aurait cru que deux hommes de plus de 70
ans pouvait maintenir une élection
longtemps cette oeuvre d'un cabinet
d'architectes est en fait complètement
bidon ce sont des détracteurs de trump
qui ont posté ces images alors regardez
ils ont imaginé la salle des tweets de
donald trump dans la bibliothèque la
salle des crimes de femelles preuves
sont acquises le président ou encore ils
ont même imaginé vous allez le voir en
prison le 9 novembre 1970
c'est sur cette table de bridge que le
général de gaulle s'effondre il est 19
heures 35
[Musique]
c'est général de détruire les détruire
l'état pendant 50 ans c'est général de
détruire la deûle à la convention cifre
en 50 ans c'est détruire l'autorité
c'est général de considérer que les
frontières ça sert plus à rien que la
nation c'est dépassé c'est général de
personnes considérant tout ça mais si
mais si c'est pour ça que nous sommes
dans cette situation ont dit le général
de gaulle il a rassemblé une nation
c'est le type qui a le plus clivée au
monde en 40
gaulliste et pétainiste pour l'algérie
pour l'indépendance contre
l'indépendance pour l'otan quand il sort
de l'otan sur 168 ya un clivage ya
lentilles dionis mais non ils évoluent
et se déroule en temps vous essaieriez
pas de brevet de goal is non mais
pourquoi ce que l'on vous m'expliquer
que peut pas du tout mais mais s'est
rien passé
mais je vous explique à quoi sert de
l'état disparu en france
regardez dans l'état et l'état a été
déterminé les français retiennent
parfois que le pape par que le détail
mais l'histoire de l'électricité des
papiers c'est une réalité une réalité et
il a refusé
le lendemain il dit à flohic son aide de
camp le lendemain sa démission il y as
flohic je vous rappelle regardez le
problème administratif je ne veux pas
toucher avant de l'état
je refuse toutes les retraites les trucs
des machins il refuse absolument tout
dans certaines régions dont
l'ile-de-france
on a l'impression d'avoir un
frémissement dans la pente épidémique
dans cette croissance que l'on voyait
continue et exponentielle ces dernières
semaines on a l'impression que ça
s'infléchit et d'ailleurs on voit dans
les services hospitaliers un petit peu
moins de patients qui arrivent dans les
services de médecine
donc oui on peut parler en région
ile-de-france d'une moi je dirais une
amorce d'un fléchissement
là encore je choque en disant c'est
quand même moins triste de mourir 84 ans
que nourrir à 20
ou 30 ans on ne peut pas indéfiniment
sacrifier deux générations à la santé de
leurs grands parents
ça je le continue de le penser donc
voila ce confinement plus light me
choque un peu moins mais quand même
souhaité ans que ça dure pas trop
longtemps
c'est à la mi journée que les
laboratoires pfizer et biotech ont levé
une vague d'espoir dans le monde
'l'annonce c'est un vaccin contre le
coronavirus il est en phase iii
d'expérimentation la dernière avant
l'homologation
le cac 40 a vraiment les bondi dans les
minutes qui ont suivi cette annonce
vous allez voir 5034 points à 12h30
c'est à dire un quart d'heure avant l'
annonce un quart d'heure après 5234
point ça fait une hausse de plus de 10%
alors une pareille hausse en si peu de
temps c'est absolument rarissime
je pense pouvoir dire que cet inédit
nous pensons que nous pouvons produire
jusqu'à 50 millions de doses
cette année un milliard trois cents
millions l'année prochaine